la garçonne 82 sur un garçon évolue et
adapté à la femme d'aujourd'hui oreilles
totalement dégagé ou tout en dégradé
avec et fils à jo ciseaux longueur des
mèches 3 à 4 cm maximum
vous avez remarqué sur le front les
mèches longues et effilée effleurant les
styles aux coûts toujours plus pour mais
vous le voyez ce n'est plus à coiffure
plaqué d'autrefois la garçonne 82 se
veut légère à errer tout en liberté
autres versions possibles la nuque
profonde avec cheveux plus longs coupés
en pointe
la garçonne coiffure pratique certes
recoiffer nous assure-t-on en deux coups
de brosse et trois coups de pelle
mais une coiffure tout même peu
économique car elle demande en a fait
des mises en plis permanente et
régulière et aussi des coups assez
fréquentes
quant à vous messieurs résolument vous
aurez les chevaux plus long il faut vous
y faire
si vous n'avez pas les 17 ayez au moins
lâchez vos murs